♪
>> Dana: AMERICAN CITIES
ARE SO OUT OF CONTROL THAT
THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT IS
USING VIDEO OF HOMELESS
PEOPLE IN PHILADELPHIA IN
A NEW ANTI-DRUG AD.
MEXICO IS USING IT TO
SCARE KIDS THERE, BUT OF
COURSE THE PHILLY MAYOR'S
OFFICE BLAMED THE OPIOID
CRISIS AS PART OF A
NATIONAL EPIDEMIC.
HE SAID IT IS HARD TO SEE
OUR CITIES AND
NEIGHBORHOODS PORTRAYED IN
NEGATIVE LIGHT.
NO NEIGHBORHOOD AND PERSON
SHOULD BE DEFINED BY THE
TRAGIC, WIDESPREAD CRISIS.
IF THAT'S NOT ENOUGH,
HERE'S A STATE.
1 OUT OF 179 AMERICANS
WILL EVENTUALLY BE
MURDERED OVER THE COURSE
OF THEIR LIFE TIMES IF THE
MURDER RATE REMAINS AT
2020 LEVELS ACCORDING TO A
NEW STUDY.
THAT'S A STARTLING
STATISTIC.
AS WE TALKED, THAT'S OVER
THE COURSE OF A LIFETIME.
BUT ANYWAY, IT IS A NUMBER
THAT CAN SCARE YOU.
>> Greg: CAN YOU LOWER IT
IF YOU ARE THE MURDERER?
>> Dana: CHANCES?
>> Greg: I WOULD RATHER BE
THE MURDERER.
THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
MEXICANS COMING HERE,
TAKING OUR JOBS.
WE'RE THE ONES SUPPOSED TO
SAY HOW BAD PHILLY IS, NOT
MEXICO.
ALSO, THERE WAS ANOTHER
SIDE TO THE STORY THAT WAS
REALLY AMAZING.
PEOPLE WERE UPSET THAT
THEY DIDN'T GET CONSENT
FROM THE PEOPLE BEING
FILMED.
I'M THINKING SORRY, DID
THE DRUG ADDICTED ZOMBIE
GET YOUR CONSENT WHEN THEY
DEFECATED IN FRONT OF A
PACKED SCHOOL BUS?
I THINK IT GOES OUT THE
WINDOW WHEN STUFF IS GOING
OUT OF THEIR BODIES ON A
SIDEWALK.
IT SAYS SOMETHING NOW THAT
OUR COUNTRY IS A
CAUTIONARY WARNING.
WE ARE NOW THE S HOLE
COUNTRY.
I DON'T SEE A WAY OUT
UNTIL WE HAVE LEGAL
ALTERNATIVES FOR OUR OWN
OBLIVION.
>> Dana: WHAT DID YOU
THINK OF THIS VIDEO,
KATIE?
>> Katie: EMBARRASSING
THAT A COUNTRY LIKE MEXICO
RAVAGED WITH CARTEL CRIME
BECAUSE OF THE DRUG TRADE
IN MEXICO IS NOW USING
THIS AS A WARNING.
IT IS HORRIBLE.
IT IS LARGELY PREVENTABLE.
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE BEING
EMBARRASSED ON A NATIONAL
SCALE, LEADERSHIP IN
PHILADELPHIA ISN'T WILLING
TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT
AND THEY ACT LIKE PEOPLE
IN THAT VIDEO WHO ARE ON
THE STREETS, THAT IT IS
THE HUMANE THING TO DO TO
ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE
LIVING THAT WAY.
GENERALLY SPEAKING, MEXICO
HAS DONE VERY LITTLE TO
PREVENT WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN AMERICAN CITIES.
YOU SEE PEOPLE COMING
OVER, DRUGS COME OVER, THE
MEXICAN SIDE OF THE BORDER
DOING NOTHING TO STOP IT.
YOU SEE THEM WORK WITH
CHINA TO CONTINUE TO
TRAFFIC THE DRUGS INTO THE
UNITED STATES.
SO IT IS EMBARRASSING AND
THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE OF
PHILADELPHIA AND OTHER
CITIES IN AMERICA HAVE THE
POWER TO CHANGE THINGS AND
THEY REFUSE TO.
>> Greg: DO THEY HAVE A
DRUG PROBLEM IN MEXICO.
>> Dana: NOT SO BAD
APPARENTLY.
WHAT ABOUT HOMETOWN
FEELINGS THERE, JESSE.
>> Jesse: I'M NOT PROUD OF
THAT MOMENT AND I DON'T
LIKE THE FACT THAT MEXICO
IS TARGETING MY HOMETOWN,
BUT IT IS MEXICO.
AND KATIE SAID IT.
COME ON.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MEXICO
HERE.
NOT LIKE CANADA IS SAYING
THIS, IT IS MEXICO.
>> Greg: I LIKE MEXICO, I
WILL TAKE MEXICO OVER
CANADA.
>> Jesse: FOR WHAT,
VACATION?
SO WOULD I.
>> Greg: EVERYTHING.
TRUDEAU.
>> Katie: WHAT IS THE
MURDER RATE IN MEXICO
VERSUS CANADA?
A LOT WORSE IN MEXICO.
>> Dana: THE MAYOR SAYS
THEY THINK THEY NEED TO DO
MORE, BUT WHAT ARE THEY
WAITING FOR?
>> Jesse: HE HAS TO DECIDE
WHAT TO DO.
DO YOU WANT TO LET THEM
KILL THEMSELVES ON THE
STREETS, SHOOT UP DRUGS,
NOT ARREST THEM?
DO YOU WANT TO GIVE THEM
NEEDLES?
DO YOU WANT TO HAVE A
GOVERNMENT OPERATED SAFE
INJECTION SITE?
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
HEADING.
YOU CAN SET UP A TENT
SITE, YOU CAN BE NAKED.
>> Greg: THAT DOESN'T
WORK.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN SHOOT
DRUGS, BE ON DRUGS,
PROBABLY GET HIT BY CARS,
AND THEY'RE NOT REALLY
POLICING THIS AREA, IF YOU
NOTICED, THIS AREA IS AN
UNPOLICED ZONE.
IT IS LIKE SOUTH SIDE OF
CHICAGO.
NORTH PHILLY IS SIMILAR.
YOU HAVE THIS MASSIVE
EXPANSE OF ROW HOMES
THAT'S UNPOLICED BECAUSE
IT IS HARD TO POLICE THESE
TYPES OF NEIGHBORHOODS
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, IT IS
HARD TO SEE AROUND CORN HE
IS, ROW HOMES ARE ALL
CONNECTED, GUYS CAN RUN
ROOFTOPS, LOT OF TIMES CAN
GO UNDERNEATH, THEY DON'T
POLICE THEM AND RESPOND TO
GUNFIRE.
THAT'S NOT PROACTIVE
POLICING.
AND THEY'VE GIVEN UP THE
WAR ON DRUGS.
DOING A STORY TOMORROW ON
JESSE WATTERS PRIME TIME,
A DEA AGENT ADMITTED TO
SKIMMING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF CASH SEIZURES
FROM WORK IN CENTRAL AND
SOUTH AMERICA, SPENDING IT
AT STRIP CLUBS, GOING ON
RIDES ON YACHTS, BUYING
HIKING GIRLFRIEND AN
ENGAGEMENT RING FROM
TIFFANY HE A.
HE IS INVOLVED, THERE ARE
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTORS
INVOLVED.
THE WHOLE THING LOOKS LIKE
THE WAR ON DRUGS IS A
JOKE, FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT GUYS ARE
MAKING MONEY OFF IT, USING
IT TO BUY STRIPPERS.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF ALL OF THIS, JESSICA?
>> Jessica: A COUPLE OF
THINGS, A LARGE CHUNK OF
THIS AD IS FOCUSED ON
FENTANYL, HOW ADDICTIVE IT
IS.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS JUST
SUCH A LOW BLOW BECAUSE
THEY KNOW WHERE THE
FENTANYL IS COMING FROM.
YOU'RE HARD PRESSED TO
FIND IT IN AMERICA THAT
DIDN'T COME FROM MEXICO OR
CHINA FIRST VIA MEXICO.
IT FELT MORE AGGRESSIVE
THAN JUST BEING ABOUT
PHILADELPHIA.
WE'LL SEE IF THERE WILL BE
CHANGES.
THE NEW GOVERNOR OF
PENNSYLVANIA HAS GONE
AFTER THE D.A. IN PHILLY,
SAID IT CAN'T STAY THIS
WAY.
WE'LL SEE IF SOMETHING
CHANGES.
THIS ALMOST SEEMED LIKE A
HIT AGAINST THE WHOLE
COUNTRY AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, RIGHT.
AN AD THAT CAME OUT AROUND
RE-ELECTION, SO DEMOCRATS
TOOK CONTROL OF THE
SENATE, HELD ON BETTER
THAN EVERYONE THOUGHT IN
TERMS OF THE HOUSE, ONLY A
COUPLE SEATS DOWN.
TO THROW THIS INTO THE ECO
SPHERE FELT MORE THOUGHT
OUT.
>> Jesse: MAGA MEXICO?
>> Dana: KAMALA HARRIS
CALLED HER MEXICAN COUNTER
PART AND SAID KNOCK IT
OFF?
>> Jessica: I HOPE SO.